every esport has its fair share of
iconic moments nitro does have a model
of another smoke so it could be really
rough for simple to actually get through
this he's going to throw the awp oh my
god
it's happening but there are certain
plays that only the most mechanically
gifted players or teams are able to pull
off some of them it can take hundreds if
not thousands of hours to master but the
results can be magical so we wanted to
take a look at some of the most
difficult plays without further ado here
are the top 10 hardest plays in esports
history
kicking off our list we have one of the
most legendary clutches in rainbow six
history kansan are you a miracle worker
you only need one more
and there it is at si 2022 sonic's
kansan pulled off an incredible clutch
to win map one of their upper quarter
final match up versus dom juan gaming
now what makes this play especially
difficult is the fact that he's using
mute's smg-11 against much better
weapons like lmgs or rifles despite the
smg's insane recoil tiny magazine and
high rate of fire canson showed a
mastery of the gun to close out the map
katzen getting softened up there goes
grixer as well and all of a sudden it's
cans in but a beautiful double play
trying to ride out the final four
seconds he has no idea where that
diffuser is smg up they're watching in
this position as he goes to swing out
there's both coded and katsang watching
from this angle kansan are you a miracle
worker you only need one more
and there it is one of the best plays
that we've seen at this tournament
kansan staved off over time and sonics
went on to win the second map of the
series to extend their impressive run at
the event
last packing his way into our number
nine spot is g2's nukia is he the
playmate because he gets g2 into this
round again oh wow it's just aerial
movements this guy's a gymnast nukia
valerant has been out for nearly two
years now but only a handful of top
players have managed to master movement
with reyes's blast packs reyes has one
of the highest skill ceilings in the
entire game and in a match against the
defending world champs nuka proved that
he's pretty close to that ceiling nukia
opened the round with a kill on the
enemy viper before running towards a
side heaven now the idea was that he was
going to blast pack up into heaven and
probably peak his opponents as they
rotated through spawn but instead the
enemy rays popped old and shot it his
way while still in the air nukia threw a
blast pack out towards heaven pushing
him back towards the site and away from
the showstopper as he fell to the ground
he instantly headshotted zeke completing
one of the sickest plays we've ever seen
then he closed out the round with an ace
what a beast one smoke available nukia
now extends from the showers and
confirms his as he finds all five and
does it in disgusting style
falling into our number eight spot we
have squishies stealing shot versus
method at the rlcs season four world
championship
now the final minute this was the score
line in game three
wild nine
unable to take it but squishy
in the early days of rocket league
simple double taps and flicks were
enough to impress casters and viewers
but as players started to develop more
advanced mechanics
one move was becoming more and more
popular the ceiling shot the ceiling
shot is a move in rocket league where
you drive up the wall and onto the
ceiling as you're falling downwards
you're still able to dodge in any
direction which allows you to take a
shot on net though the mechanic was
first spotted in some of jazer's early
montages squishy popularized it in
ranked and in cloud nine's lower bracket
final against method he finally brought
out one of rocket league's hardest shots
on the game's biggest stage now the
final minute this was the score line in
game three
wild nine
unable to take it to squishy now
he's been going for this enough all
season and he pulls it off here in the
most clutch moments the player to invent
the shot him
to get the delayed front flip and just
destroy method on defense even they have
to be impressed
in our number seven spot it's proof that
sometimes the hardest plays are all
about coordination
back at the 2018 chongqing major
qualifiers alliance pulled off one of
dota's most incredible team plays to
kick things off tyga blinked into the
roche pit as madness and used reverse
polarity to group and stun four team
liquid members before skewering them out
of the pit and into the welcoming arms
of his enigma who black-holed the entire
group
what a wombo combo
oh my god they did it
oh my god elias pulls off the
combination of not just this game but
possibly quite possibly the decade
slicing his way into our sixth spot is
eqo with his heroic genji play at the
2020 summer showdown everyone is weak
equal with a blade pulls it through
builds it up will it be enough one kill
two kill are you kidding me on the final
map of the grand finals eqo saved the
fusion with this incredible genji play
it all started off with his opening kill
on widowmaker before taking down
baptiste and orissa this charged up his
ult which dropped sigma 2 leaving him
against another genji taking pot shots
at him far away from the objective if
eqo died the fusion would lose if he
left the objective to deal with the
genji the fusion would also lose so eqo
did both he ran to genji killed him
reset his dash and made it back to the
payload just in time to keep the game
alive sadly the fusion went on to lose
the match but if it wasn't for his
insane heroics in this moment then the
game would have ended right then and
there and boombox just left to his own
devices in the sidelines he goes down
the fusion only a couple of players left
remaining eqo is going to come up huge
right now
everyone is weak eq over the blade pulls
it through builds it up will it be
enough one kill to kill are you kidding
me
eqo now finds it with the third and now
it is overtime actually moving over to
the tracer to try and deny but eq oh
equal
what a player what a star
kiting his way into the halfway point on
our list is viper but morgana i can't
find it either viper stays alive that's
the full pentakill viper is one of the
most mechanically gifted adc's in league
of legends and during griffin's
quarterfinal match versus ig at worlds
2019 he reminded everyone why griffin
were backed into a corner down 0-2 in
the series and staring down a losing
team fight they needed a big play to
lock down game 3 and extend the series
that's when viper turned it all around
he took down the enemy vlad before
popping zaya's featherstorm just in time
to avoid getting blown up by rookie and
killed him instead next the adc went
down and finally viper perfectly timed a
cleanse to stop morgana's binding from
ending his rampage before killing her
and the lee sin what a monster when will
they find it what's the play forward
they go they might have knocked him down
puts down the pool but is there enough
damage they're gonna try they hold over
the top but it's already a two for zero
fight for he doesn't die but one finally
comes through it's up to jackie love but
he gets stunned clutch from tarzan but
morgana i can't find it either viper
stays alive that's the full
pentakill
driving his way into our fourth spot is
a chronic back flips away from the ball
chronic flip side
oh my goodness look you already saw how
insane ceiling shots can be but in
rocket league there's nothing more hype
than hitting a flip reset on your
opponent flip resetting is one of the
most difficult mechanics to master in
the entire game it requires touching the
ball with the underside of your car this
makes the game think that you have
touched the surface like a wall ceiling
or ground and allows you to get another
flip over time players have been pushing
the limits of flip resetting and many
freestylers can pull off a double and
even triple flip resets but what makes a
chronic's play special is that he did it
in pro play when the pressure is on
players rarely have the time or space to
set up correctly for flip resets but a
chronic made it work will it chronic be
able to redeem himself there's still
time
oh
smeller just
clips away from the ball
there's one
there's two
and there's the goal shot that
was pre-jumped right in the way of him
punching his way into our number three
spot is west balls zelda free teching
too smart for westballz's tech chase
look at him trying to dash and scrap
around falcons here and dying for all
right oh no oh my gosh now for those of
you who are unfamiliar with wes he's
famous for always going for high risk
high reward punishes he's a tech god but
a lot of his tech can go really wrong if
you're not perfect at kings of cali 3
wes showed off one of smash's most
technical high-risk plays the sacred
combo requires you to read your
opponent's di and predict where they're
going to end up or it won't work at all
predicting his opponent was going to die
in west took a chance and hit a short
hop sweet spot fair into a dash full hop
falcon punch for an instant ko if his
opponent had died away he would have
falcon punched the air and died the
combo isn't just hard because of the
timing it's also all about situational
awareness this particular scenario is so
rare that this is one of the very very
few secret combos ever hit in a real
match zelda freak teching too smart for
westballz's tech chase look at him
trying to dash and scrap around falcon
snare and dying all right
oh my gosh
the man of the century zelda freak
knowing that that can only work if you
dies for your opponent and the gentleman
he is zelda freak d-ing for the sacred
combo and fulfilling everyone's dreams
here at king's cali3
in our runner-up spot is faker's most
famous play his legendary dunk on ryu
i'm like even though i only have a mat
on the floor i think he's in the bed oh
faker may be in trouble you're dead mark
tries to clean it up for ryu oh look at
the class look at the moves faker what
was that in game five of ogn champion
summer 2013 a young faker announced
himself to the world in a mid-lane
mirror matchup against kt rolsters ryu
skt were starting to pull ahead when
faker overstepped at the mid-lane
inhibitor turret he should have died for
that but instead he did something
incredible faker and ryu traded blade of
the ruined king activations while faker
tanked tower shots and e and auto and
ignite that's when faker turned things
around by using death mark to become
invulnerable to ignite damage ryu ulted
in response so figure juked with his
death shadow and avoided damage before
popping quicksilver sash to nullify the
ignite and reuse alt then faker comboed
his q ignite and auto attack and briefly
flash to safety ryu tried to flash and
auto attack faker in response but the
unkillable demon king was a step ahead
of him picker used his living shadow one
more time to get to safety before
dealing the final blow with his shadow
slash faker went on to lift his first
lck trophy and ryu has been tortured by
the play ever since
even though i only have a mat on the
floor i think he's in the bed oh faker
may be in trouble or death park tries to
clean it up for ryu oh look at the class
look at the moves faker what was that
in our number one spot is one of
esports's most iconic moments ever the
daigo parry
[Applause]
it was daigo vs justin wong at evo
2004's third strike losers finals daigo
was down to a pixel of hp he was dead to
literally any attack whether he blocked
it or not so justin threw out a super
figuring it was basically checkmate in
street fighter 3 a perfectly timed parry
can nullify all damage but chun's
holyoke son super art is 15 hits daigo
had to predict the super was coming to
parry the first hit at all and then time
each and every parry perfectly after
that to even survive let alone win and
to make things even harder justin
started mashing an attempt to throw off
daigo's rhythm
[Music]
[Applause]
these days players have spent time
grinding out the exact timing for this
play but back in the day this was the
most mechanically demanding thing in
fighting games and doing this in the top
8 at evo only makes it more impressive
alright everyone that's our list if you
think we missed one let us know down in
the comment section below take care and
i'll see you in the next one
gonna be torn away from them very very
quickly by scientists oh my god nico
three and four oh my lungs i don't
believe it shocks then that's just to
find one more the molly isn't going to
touch him
and what on earth has just happened is
deagle is on fire and sharks is going to
walk into it as well nico is on fire